bob saget's cause of death has been
revealed
in a statement released to e.t on
wednesday the saggett family shared
details they've learned from the
investigation
saga died on january 9th the late
comedian was found unresponsive in his
hotel room following a stand-up
performance in florida he was 65. the
statement explains quote the authorities
have determined that bob passed from
head trauma they have concluded that he
accidentally hit the back of his head on
something thought nothing of it and went
to sleep no drugs or alcohol were
involved the family also expressed
gratitude for the outpouring of support
following saggett's death they wrote in
the statement quote in the weeks since
bob's passing we have been overwhelmed
with the incredible outpouring of love
from bob's fans which has been a great
comfort to us and for which we are
eternally grateful he is nice and i will
say never a dull moment he's just the
most pure heart ever the family ended
their statement with a tribute it reads
quote we ask everyone to remember the
love and laughter that bob brought to
this world and the lessons he taught us
all to be kind to everyone to let the
people you love know you love them and
to face difficult times with hugs and
laughter
it's been almost a month
where are you at how are you right now
um i'm still very much grieving et
recently sat down with two members of
saggett's full house family candace
cameron beret and jody sweetin
the actresses opened up about the loss
of their on-screen dad
look look at his camera look
at his camera look she's my tv daughter
he was the real deal i can't stress that
enough but you know someone's the real
deal when you have that many people
speaking about you and have so much love
for you he would help he would drop
anything to help anyone and um
and and they didn't have to be
they were not celebrity people not
high-powered people it was just like
your mom's grandma's aunt needs help
okay what can i do for her the good
thing is i i feel like we're all gonna
feel his presence all the time because
that's the kind of person he was but i'm
i'm
i'm always waiting for him to
text and chime in and make a joke i'm
like waiting like come on
when is this going to happen and i know
it's not going to happen
when we would say it over the years i
don't and and still even as much as
we've said it and as much as people have
seen it i really don't think anyone can
truly understand just how close
we really really were when someone
passes all of a sudden you think about
all the things that you've learned from
them and how important they've been and
i just realized so much of
his genuineness and and his kindness and
his ability to help others
really impacted me